spoole a Capcom with the homie crooked I
long beaches finest in the building
what's up y'all
crook man how was everything I can't
complain did the static album was crazy
thank you sir very kind of unexpected I
know stack was telling me you guys are
working on and I was I was I was like I
cannot wait to hear what this thing
sounds like it was amazing
yeah how'd you guys that clean-cut and
we was talking about doing it for a long
time and then you know I go you just
keep talking about it in till Abbas I
think we was backstage out of prime Shaw
and we I think static was like yo man we
need to go ahead and make this happen
looking at Royce and premiere up there
he's like yeah we need to go and make
this happen on my night send a beat it
was that it was that easy a lot of
people don't do it anymore with the
whole entire cohesive sound what's the
latest with horseshoe gang man some of
the most underrated dudes in the game I
always say man they doing it then they
got a brand new help me call four
brothers coming out in September you
know I'm saying they just shot a few
videos an hour late for that they just
stay working I mean Odin Brothers right
there man they just they don't ever stop
they just around the clock work grind
grind grind I saw Dino so everybody be
looking out for that four brothers
horseshoe yeah I'm Sam hey um I always
remember when I bought when I was a kid
I got duped by Death Row Records I
bought the chronic 2000 that was that
remember that scene yeah you thought it
was the trailer yeah and there was I do
it when there to sound just like Snoop
was his name
merry homey sounded just like Snoop you
talking about yeah yeah dog in his man
to our remember me I was like hey they
even found a fakes new but yo you were
not one top dog it might have been a lot
of been tough it might have a little
before TD top dog now but you were you
were around that in the and the wake up
show was kind of where I first heard of
you what was it like being around
death-row records during the after the
glory I guess I should say I mean cuz
you were on the double XL covered with
them and right yeah and all that it was
uh it was interesting it was enough to
write a book about you know sugar was
locked up when I did my deal with
you know and I basically negotiated my
contract in the penitentiary on the
penitentiary visit and you know after
that it was just making music you know
he had a lot of money though right so
the money was flowing but the music
wasn't really coming out in my opinion
people was trying to blackballed me I'm
short you know it was just even worse
like they showed in love when he was
around of course on his he left it was
like you know when they're not with that
kid like they don't want to see him back
in power so you know my whole ordeal on
death row was just basically traveling
Hawaii and the Bahamas and this getting
them checking the life of a rap star
without putting out any music you know
that was before mixtapes and stuff yeah
so it's like you know I want to put out
music oh this is cool but I'm like
they'll trying to put some music it's
funny you say that and like you started
one of the biggest trends in hip-hop
which is putting out weekly releases you
were the first guy to ever do that you
did a year straight right yesterday
fifty-two records yeah that's like still
something that I don't think anybody has
ever done in a year straight yeah people
do it they'll do it you know here and
there but but 52 weeks in a row is crazy
how much music like do you are you
sitting on from that period because I
assume you have so much music my music
and plus I never stopped working like
you know
I'm in the can right now and I'm working
on two EPs so I just never stop working
I just sit on gangs and music gangs
let's talk about that Joe Budden he's
been going at Drake pretty heavy right
what do you think of the records I think
they're all fire obviously Joe's got
bars but what do you think of the entire
he's put out four records I think so far
what is your take on the entire Joe
Budden Drake thing I think Joey is uh he
to me from a distance it just looks like
a disappointed fan well I think you know
what I'm saying
it's not like a beef to me is like you
know he thought jokes holding him
accountable as a fan hasn't ran yeah
like telling him like y'all I don't like
were you going right now creative you
know creatively uh he listened to views
he had his opinion on views he'd put it
on his car go that podcast it shows you
how powerful that podcast is cuz it's so
many things he's mentioned on a podcast
if like caused him you know rifts
already which tells you people are
really listening listening and you know
he heard that he heard the drake record
you know a couple months before yeah
yeah there's no shopping right yeah yeah
yeah he heard that I guess he just took
that like okay he brought the start
throwing shots at me so I'm gonna gear
up and he just went into Joe mode and
went in there and did like seven or
eight records probably you know it's a
it's a trip to me to see it all unfold I
mean you know I go in this game you got
a lot of power and you got you know you
might win the battle no matter even if
you did creatively grabs and so no it's
cool to see that it's just something
that we know is gonna be on wax for sure
you know I mean cuz the ball too many
times the beef spillover industries now
you got all these other [__] and go now
I got the voice the meme of the century
today did you see the video
some fans like kind of came at him and
then he checked them I think it's kind
of [__] up too that like like what
would you expect somebody to do like if
you're a real dude and somebody comes at
you sideways and like you chase them
down like well you just get props for
that isn't in my this is bizarro world
you know that never the world of memes
man everything is everything is reversed
you know then back in the edges pimping
pimps and you know
is like real is fake to people you know
how to say yeah Maggie Wow being weird
is cool now everything is just is
reversed it was like you know it was all
Meeks here cuz meek wouldn't respond on
wax but now they make up excuses why
Drake [__] right you know what I say the
same people so hundred percent is this
it's just a big bizarro world thing man
I don't know you know Joe you're gonna
be Joe talk about what you got coming up
next
obviously you put out a couple projects
in the last one year sex money and
hip-hop came out sex money in hip-hop
that did good for me I mean you know we
we just pressed that up and basically
just did it old-school style
what I want to really go online too much
with that you say you're working on a
couple of EPS working on some EPS oh my
god oh how good versus evil it's coming
out probably September or something like
that is done this in a can it's a
different type of album for me because
it's like a concept bout doing it
through so I think the fans might like
that I've been just working on this on
my TV show you log on a TV show I didn't
know it yeah it's called one shot what
it is it's like an American Idol
strictly for hip-hop I think I did hear
about this so you know this is swayable
yeah wooden Gus way to hold it you know
I'm saying that's right that's right we
go city to city looking for new rap
stars we did the deal with BT you know
so the show will be out you know I'm
saying August 23rd is going air on BT
that's don't know you know a nice check
you know you know your got to do that
too but it is just dope because we was
able to go city the city to city to city
and see all this brand new talent we was
a Chicago 5,000 MCS showed up you know
I'm saying right and
same in Atlanta same in AMS crazy and we
have celebrity guest judges in Atlanta
we had Ti and DJ drama it's real dope I
just think that it's gonna change
hip-hop because it's too many people
that don't get a shine it's full circle
too because like I said man I remember
copping them sway free stuff waynetech
freestyle tapes back and intake is a
judge on the show oh go oh yeah that's
all for my family you know I think more
people should do that you know when you
get a chance to put do something big
go back to the people who helped you
even be in a position to do that you
know I'm saying is swag definitely did
that for me so this is dope man BT on
August the other was shot what's your
thoughts on the the double XL freshmen
cover it I feel like I understand why a
lot of the guys made it but as far as
rapping talent it's probably the lowest
that it's been not to say that those
guys don't make good records and and
have their lane but but you know it's
getting a lot of flack for well double I
don't I mean you know I think that a lot
of these magazines you know I think that
the big thing is advertising dollars
right so you know it's like if the
advertisers are happy it's automatic
that's all that matters you know all the
hip-hop fans the pure hip-hop fans they
might not like it and that's just what
it is I mean my only argument what that
is is when doubled Excel creates a
platform for a young artists that come
freestyle do a cypher do anything you
know go home write your bars out you
don't care if you get in the mirror you
know if you're watching those freestyle
watch they're a bad thing is is if if
you're just gonna walk in to a platform
like double XL and just come off the
head like that's kind of you gotta be
separate you got to be super NAT or
somebody yeah I'm not super that yeah
it's kind of disrespectful to the
coaches but disrespectful to the
platform that they given you is
disrespectful to the fans who pay for
this [__] yeah I feel like the only guys
who really like killed it I really like
little dickie honestly Dave Davies is
hard to the and tells though and I think
that we got to stop looking at this like
Haven this is an opinion and there's
also a veteran I've been in the game a
long time it's just somebody telling you
some real [__] straight up so I think
when it comes to the youngsters you know
when they 19 on the ground they think
that's all like the whole jeez they're
hating yeah oh geez I hate it's not a
hater movies really just pulling your
coattail to tell you that it's greater
if you study your craft and if you put
something together that's worth
everybody watching and all that because
now now look you did double XL and then
it really had an impact you wanted to
cuz people are mad that it wasn't fire
so go home make it fire then go get on
double XL hey so um I gotta talk to you
because I'm good friends with everybody
involved here the whole entire was
[__] bottoms not even around anymore
but talk about what that was like that
battle was I thought was pretty dope
like I thought you're getting an option
yeah I thought horseshoe gang did their
thing a lot of thing yes horseshoe
Ganga's hungry so anytime somebody said
he can rap better than them they Adam
just automatically you know I feel like
absent I know for a fact cuz I'm yeah
because now that they're not together
but dizzy and and jaren it kind of like
they were kind of like Yoho you're kind
of throwing that out there
yeah yeah and so they kind of like by
association after job in or I win it and
right the situation is what it is you
see that is quite possible that hop
wasn't even really [__] with them
yeah you selfs and at the time when they
were loyal to him you know what I mean
but I mean I think it's I know that
there was a I know dizzy was really he
was that he was a little perturbed
because everything was squashed and then
I think you had gotten mad because after
you guys had a conversation I think hop
posted retweeted something from a fan
somebody yeah on Twitter that said like
horseshit gang or something after you
guys already squashed it and that
you
when you squash them you're supposed to
be squash the shorts and I mean but at
the end of the day I talk behalf you
know I talked to Damon like there's good
people you know at the end of the day I
really believe that Hopson and Dane made
a good team I wish - I wish they would
expose together - stuck together or if
the phone volume flag-waving you know
things get my little brothers man
they're not worried about nobody when it
kind of wrapping I don't even care of
jay-z step in the room and say he want a
piece of that butter straight straight
to him it's just that's just how we were
bred we don't we don't see celebrity
status we see somebody saying that they
better than us
hey coming from Long Beach there's a
couple of uh really I mean I love Vince
staples staples Joyce as I was gonna ask
you about tiny C style ot Genesis is
from there we see a lot of people don't
know that because he's sitting like a
few things from Atlanta there's
somewhere downtown you travel you pick
up flavors from dude but he sees he's
from your hometown what's your
relationship like with those younger
dudes that are coming out of well nice
all of us all of you know I have CL B
radio with DJ Skee for a while yeah and
we had ot on the show you know and a lot
of people before a lot of people knew
how you know he had a couple records in
that Jackie Chan record yeah Jackie that
was fresh him and
you know and now he's doing this thing
man I love to see it you know I just
love to see it like I'm reaching out to
him now I might try to see if I can get
him just gonna got a deuce on TV show
yes happy Tiger do yes keep the city
moving you know the right obviously
everybody's always going to ask is there
what's up with the third well there was
an EP but what's up with the third
slaughterhouse album
uh I mean slaughterhouses is a different
thing it's like you dead you got four
dudes doing a bunch of [__] and then you
you know you know how it go in the guy
short when it's time to put a put your
album out you gotta you gotta kind of
like a specially now that you guys are
signed alike you can analyze four months
of time it aside put aside to promo you
know I mean so trying to get four dudes
who are doing it all doing jobs or X's
you know it's a my dicks crazy layers is
crazy you know what I'm saying it's like
now you got a shift gears and you got to
go four months straight with promo
together you know what I'm saying it's
just a timing thing cuz when I'm ready
you know well I'm always ready but when
you know where people already is like
okay what is person ain't ready or that
person already so here's one in the fans
they get in sick of a man I go post you
know happy Mother's Day and if fans
would be like where to [__]
slaughterhouse out like that's all they
want don't care I'm curious like I felt
like some of the records on the on the
last album I was a little disappointed
with the last album right there was some
great records or some records I wasn't
crazy about but it felt like some of the
records like the record was CeeLo kind
of felt like a little just kind of felt
a little contrived like like you know
like and in this one I were making this
record we're making it to try to and
it's funny that it sounded like that
because it wasn't that way or whatnot I
thought when the became on way you know
had that 87 right you know what I'm
saying so we went in there we did what
we did and I mean I was it just wasn't
like listened to my life in particular
the song you talk right now listen to
the lyrics
the cadence the patter stir the
multi-syllable flows on there you don't
ever aim those anti brain crossover
obviously you know what I'm saying
so when we were in there we just took a
sample that we liked I want to see you
guys that whole album engine ways I know
and that's all I want and then what we
use si lo we we know CeeLo goody mob of
course we just you know this ain't the
TV show this real Oh like CeeLo is that
dude see look at bars you know what I'm
saying yeah that's like is this all but
people always say that but they want to
go like either tonight if I pull that
song out they go right I just think what
it was man is I think that first
Waterhouse always should have been put
out differently in my paper I I think I
think hammered - should have been the
main focus like not not a not a street
buzz record like that it was it let's
push hammer day because that's a
slaughterhouse whereas a slaughterhouse
and in reco and it was dope you know go
ahead I think you know what you live and
you learn of me dog we had came from the
mud like we came from major labels to
independent grind for years and then
y'all doing major yeah and it was like
okay so now what you know what I'm
saying like we really was in there just
happy to be [__] with no IP what was
it like that first that first tour when
you guys hopped onto her attack that was
made us men we weren't minuted they
tec-9 have those goes crazy rosen in
check yet back then because i know how
yeah we almost walked up strange music
guys ain't that brazen they had the rule
book we set the strange compound it was
like i just the rule book we pulled our
management to the side like y'all come
on man we not gonna it was like y'all
ready to get the [__] out of here but uh
naw but it was cool because you know
tech work we did like 60 shows in like
65 days you know what i'm saying and
that was just back to back to back to
back I mean sometimes you don't get a
hotel room
you gotta just go to a truck stop paying
$10 put on some shower shoes take a
shower real quick get back on the bus
keep it movin you
it was really one of those tours where
you don't get to see a barb or you'll
get the layup in the fly hotel you don't
get to hit the after-party Club you
don't do none of that you just boom boom
boom there cuz I've Ike I think the
curfew is like 2 a.m. or something let's
try to leave me of many outsmarting him
you'd okay I paid the goddamn bus driver
go there wait yeah just wait on me and
then pull over on the side of freeway
they don't all go to sleep they don't
think the bus is moving I'm gonna meet
you on the side hi oh man I know you
that toured with Ritz you and rich got
to do a record together man uh well I
did the laughs remix book oh you did
that's right that's right yeah yeah yeah
that was crazy
that is true that was the riff store was
nice now that was a dope tour you guys
got I've ever seen you on Tampa [__]
[__] faded forever away he had the
crown gone I had the Jama cigar we was
having a contest just getting told to
[__] up word up would look uh you're
worried about the shows August 21st on
bt august 23rd 2013 one shot you know
I'm saying make sure you watch it good
versus evil I'm coming to September you
know I made and just trying to create
more platforms for up-and-coming artists
that's really what I'm dedicated to
right now it's waterhouse album I guess
we'll [__] see but your button stops
dissing drinks word up